c'est la fin d'une époque avec moins il
y a moins de 10 ans ça faisait encore un
million de téléspectateurs aujourd'hui
ils font péniblement 400 500 000 et le
problème c'est que dans cette
télé-réalité il y a plus aucune réalité
les candidats ils sont fails qui jouent
la comédie ils se mettent en couple
uniquement pour exister dans l'émission
il y avait des pseudos en jeu
professionnel aujourd'hui on sait que
c'est bidon et les téléréalités les
divertissements qui marchent aujourd'hui
c'est les divertissements avec de
l'enjeu comme la Star Academy Mario
premier regard avec un peu dangereux
L'Amour est dans le pré il y a dans le
jeu là malheureusement c'est un peu trop
light un peu trop vite donc cette
téléréalité là ouais je pense qu'elle
est morte si vous voulez relancer soit
secret soit le loft ils ont fêté les 15
ans de secret sur TFX ça a pas marché
donc là il se chauffe plutôt sur le loft
comme la star qui a marché sur TF1 ils
aimerait relancer le Story sur M6 très
bien merci que la sociologie des casting
va changer la Star Ac c'est bien parce
que les gens ils sont les jeunes les
jeunes gens sont normaux en fait c'est
des gens normaux donc il y a la
méritocratie il y a le travail à la
discipline et c'est des bonnes valeurs
positives et je pense que c'est casting
comme ça avec les esthétiques
pornographiques où toutes les filles
sont refaites au tout les mecs sont des
mêmes corps les mêmes tatouages les
mêmes trucs et tout je pense que c'est
fini c'est un mauvais exemple pour la
jeunesse et on est arrivé au bout du
bout du bout du système et c'est tant
mieux alors on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs à 19h23 voilà 83% 8